We knew they were going to try everything
to try to get Donald Trump reelected and the
next step is sabotaging the post office.
And this is super important to know about.
So, yes, Donald Trump floated yesterday the
idea of delaying the presidential election.
Unlikely to happen.
He doesn't actually have the power to do it.
He can mess up the post office pretty badly.
And that's what he's trying next.
So to set this up, Corona virus hits.
But we know we have an election coming up
in November.
OK.
Simple solution.
You vote by mail.
And when we say vote by mail, we don't mean
some new system.
We just mean expanding absentee ballot access
to anybody that wants an absentee ballot.
Whether or not corona virus is under control
in November.
We don't know.
It's increasingly looking like it's going
to be out of control.
But we expand absentee ballot access to everybody.
We've got a solution for a safe election.
Trump is against it.
Trump is against it because he says there
will be fraud.
Trump doesn't understand that vote by mail
is the same in this case as just absentee.
We're not talking about a different system.
He's either confused or he's lying or he's
distorting or whatever.
We don't know.
Well, governors mostly, fortunately, take
matters into their own hands and they expand
absentee ballots.
They in some states say everybody can get
one.
In others, they say you still have to have
a valid reason for requesting an absentee
ballot.
But fear of catching Corona virus counts as
a valid reason.
Some states are doing other types of expansions.
But for the most part, governors do the right
things.
So what is Trump's next move?
Well, he's trying to neuter and kneecap the
post office.
Donald Trump has appointed Lewis Dejoy to
be postmaster general.
Dejoy just happens to be a huge Trump donor
who wants to see Donald Trump reelected.
And Dejoy has announced that he's going to
eliminate overtime for hundreds of thousands
of postal workers.
Overtime widely expected to be needed as we
have a record number of people opting to vote
absentee rather than in-person, which could
delay mail services and, of course, prevent
the delivery of the ballots.
In other words, Trump, through his postmaster
general, is trying to cause the very problems
that he cited as the reason why we shouldn't
have vote by mail.
Lewis Dejoy is also considering closing a
bunch of post offices across the country,
and Dejoy is using kind of coded language
to try to hide his intentions, saying things
like, well, listen, we haven't done any kind
of reform in the post office for a long time.
We're going to take a fresh look at the operations
of the Postal Service.
This is all code.
Now, we know that because of Corona virus
and because we know that absentee ballot access
has been expanded in a bunch of states around
the country, there will be way more absentee
ballots this year than arguably in any prior
year.
And we are just a few weeks from the start
of that, remember, four and a half weeks from
now.
Some states start voting absentee.
So what do they want to do?
Cut the post office?
This is completely obvious.
Three months before an election, Trump puts
in a big donor to run the post office.
And immediately, Trump's donor says, whoa,
whoa, whoa, stop the clock.
Let's reduce mail service.
What people are e-mailing me saying, how is
this legal?
That's a great question.
This is extremely authoritarian, something
we're now used to with Donald Trump.
This is another example of regulatory capture
and this is another example of the right wanting
to suppress turnout.
If you can't stop people from going to the
polls as easily because lots of people are
going to be voting by mail, prevent their
ballots from being delivered by hurting the
post office.
This is the strategy and it should be mentioned.
You know, sometimes I point out Democrats
and Republicans are both part of maintaining
this status quo, where they're both mostly
onboard with expanding the military budget
or whatever.
This is not a both sides issue for is it 20
years?
Is it longer?
The right has had the strategy of trying to
hold down turnout in certain areas to try
to win elections.
The left doesn't do this.
The left doesn't consider as a top strategy
for winning elections.
Let's figure out how to prevent people from
voting or how to prevent people's votes from
counting.
So first of all, number one, we have to so
overwhelm the vote that these strategies won't
work.
I've been saying that for a year or longer,
and I hope that now everybody understands
why it's true.
Secondly, there is a maybe possible backfire
effect here.
So right now, red states have been way more
hit by corona virus than blue states for now.
This could mean that red states are doing
more online shopping because it's safer to
go shopping in blue states than red states.
And so hurting the Postal Service might actually
anger more.
Publican's than Democrats.
Now, whether they'll link it to Trump's postmaster.
And hold Trump accountable is another story.
Remember that when Obamacare passed and Republican
governors opted not to do the Medicaid expansion.
A lot of those red state voters blamed Obama.
Even though Obama gave the governors the tools,
it was the governors who opted not to do it.
They may not actually hold the right people
accountable, but they are doing it.
They're doing it right now.
This is not a dress rehearsal and that is
almost going to be the everybody must vote.
And this is not a dress rehearsal or very
quickly becoming the phrases of the next three
months